wait hi I'm ramosan Sullivan I'm social
talking of the UN Germany trap social
entrepreneurs Ian Germany I learned much
of things and I got much of impulses why
where and the most important thing I
learned here is that to beat the
economic crisis to deal with economic
crisis not money is the most important
thing I think the most important thing
is to have one voice one idea which
brings all the people together which
motivates all the people to work
together and to work against prices and
icing result this one word without this
cooperation of civil society sector of
economic sector of political sector and
of scientific sector there is no
sustainable solution possible against
the crisis and why we work against
surprises it's my seemed very important
to remember that there are people who
are not bankers or financial directors
they have much of people were workers
were simply people scholars were in
where's the problem is the crisis cool
you know so we have to find a way to
take the world because together we work
against surprises it's not only a crisis
on sale economic sector afterward by
crisis which which influence the social
of the educational the health the health
sector to influence every part of the
society sectors in whole world the other
thing is and I want to say thank you to
the politicians and the economist that I
feel that in a realistic way there there
are enough answers found it and their
reactions i I'm I'm impressed that
a little depressing this is feel about
that at the end it's suitable to that
there is a serious reaction and I think
the idea of that we were quite together
in an institution who was organizing
transfer of money was controlling too
many transfers and so on to work in
international institution this idea is
born I think nearly in 10 in 10 years we
would have such an institution I
remember the speech of Angela Merkel she
said as as a leader of a very strong
nation that she's she's sure that the
states have to give some responsibility
from yourself to an international
organization and that makes me a little
bit optimistic because if such a
important and strong leader said that
she has to give the responsibility babe
then I think it's a very strong message
and you see other strong countries Jesus
message then I think you do with
Marshall things yep the other thing I
which impressed me is that the idea the
idea of mr. Schwab thought with several
times that if you rebuild our economic
system then we have to use the chance to
make it better than before you know so
that necessary it's not only necessary
to let to reorganize it in the same way
maybe this time you will be organized in
a more ethical way in the most serious
way and so I think it's a good key
message to say you make it no better
than before and don't forget the sort
world don't forget the poor countries
I'm sure that it's necessary that if we
have problems is money now then we have
to think about third world and it's
necessary not to stop the transfer of
money to them
I'm very impressed that Germany decided
in this situation to give more to the
software it's impressive yes nice thing
to come together in Davos five days
factors we are together and I think v1
nearly three years because if all the
important actors came together come
together then they can do a lot in
between five days they get there they
can get impulses in five days they can
get ideas and strategies in five days
normally I see you need for this
strategist one two or three years and I
want to say thank you to mr. Schwab who
made it possible I think every time we
need one man who's saying okay there we
go there and then we all together go to
there and yeah and find solutions which
are in which we have all together
compounds thank you very much